the Quran affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of the gospel
and yet our Muslim friends tell us that
the gospel has been
corrupted and no matter how many times I
show our Muslim friends what the Quran
really says no matter how many times I
challenge them to show me a single Quran
verse that says the gospel has been
corrupted they continue insisting that
the Quran says something completely
different from what it actually says
since they haven't read the Quran they
always seem to assume that there must be
some verse somewhere in the Quran that
says the gospel has been corrupted
because that's what their shakes and
imams tell them it says fortunately
there is a way for all of us to finally
get to the bottom of this there is a way
to settle this dispute and see who's
right and who's been duped by lying
shakes and imams in this video we're
going to read every single verse in the
Quran that mentions the gospel if you're
watching this and you're a Muslim you're
about to learn way more about what the
Quran says about the gospel than your
shakes and imams will ever tell you they
do not want you to know this so they
hide it from you if you're watching this
and you're a non-muslim you're about to
have some awesome material for some very
interesting conversations with your
Muslim friends you're about to go from
beginner to expert level now to ensure
careful reasoning as we go through these
verses let's set up two hypotheses here
at the beginning and then we'll go
through the Quran and see which
hypothesis is confirmed by the evidence
my hypothesis we'll call it the dwood
hypothesis is this according to the
Quran Allah gave different Revelations
to different groups of people through
different prophets and those different
groups are responsible for obeying the
scriptures that were revealed to them
Christians received the gospel through
Jesus the gospel is still reliable and
authoritative and Christians are
commanded to judge by the gospel not by
the Quran that's the dwood hypothesis if
the dwood hypothesis is correct Muslims
face two major problems first the Quran
sounds like it's saying that gave a book
called The Gospel to Jesus and that
Jesus then gave this book to his
followers but the Quran says that
Christians still have the gospel and
that Christians have to judge by the
gospel since Christians have never had a
book that was given by Jesus Allah
apparently doesn't know what he's
talking about second in the Quran Allah
really seems to think that the gospel
that Christians still have agrees with
the Quran when it clearly doesn't since
Allah affirms our scriptures when our
scriptures contradict the Quran Allah
once again doesn't know what he's
talking about so that's my hypothesis
and those are the two main problems for
Islam if my hypothesis is correct then
there's the Muslim hypothesis we'll call
it the standard Islamic narrative the
standard Islamic narrative is this
according to the Quran La gave different
Revelations to different groups of
people but they were all corrupted
except the Quran Christians received the
gospel through Jesus but they corrupted
it the gospel is not reliable or
authoritative and Christians must now
judge by the Quran not by the
gospel that is what you believe isn't it
my Muslim friends that is what your
shakes and imams tell you isn't it
there's just one problem for the
standard Islamic
narrative the Quran let's go through the
Quran and read every single verse that
mentions the gospel so we can see which
hypothesis is correct now there are only
12 verses that mention the gospel if
you're taking notes the verses are Surah
3:3 Surah 3:48 Surah 3: 65 Surah 5 ver
46 Surah 5:47 Surah 5 ver 66 Surah 5 5:
68 Surah 5: 110 Surah 7 ver 157 Surah 9
ver 111 Surah 48: 29 and Surah 57 verse
27 some of these verses are perfectly
clear on their own so we can read those
on their own some of the verses require
a bit of context for those we'll read
some of the surrounding context all
right let's confirm a hypothesis and
disconfirm another h
hypothesis first up Surah 3:3 we'll read
verses 2- 4 for context God there is no
God but he the living the
self-subsisting he sent down the book
upon thee upon Muhammad in truth
confirming what was before it so the
Quran confirms what came before it and
he sent down the Torah and the gospel a
four time as a guidance to Mankind and
he sent down the criteria
truly those who disbelieve in the signs
of God shall have a severe punishment
and God is mighty possessor of
Vengeance there are a few interesting
pieces of evidence here Sur 3:3
obviously affirms the inspiration of the
Gospel it says that Allah sent down the
Torah and the gospel the verse says that
the Quran confirms what was before it
and then clarifies that it's referring
to earlier Revelations English
translations obscure another important
piece of evidence here when the Quran is
said to confirm what was before it does
this just mean before it in time is the
Quran only saying that the Torah and the
gospel were reliable when they were
originally revealed but not necessarily
later or does it mean something much
more
significant well the Arabic phrase
translated as before it is ma Yi which
literally means between his hands or
between its hands when used as an idiom
ma Yi can mean in his presence or in its
presence so it doesn't sound like the
Quran is verifying books that came
before it but were subsequently
corrupted it sounds like the Quran is
verifying books that were still
available as it was being revealed verse
four says that Allah revealed the gospel
as a guidance to mankind
this means that Muslims who say that the
gospel was corrupted early on by someone
like the Apostle Paul are telling us
that Allah failed because if they're
right the gospel was corrupted and
didn't guide
Mankind and finally we have Allah
warning people that those who disbelieve
in his signs which here refers to his
Revelations shall have a severe
punishment so if Allah is affirming not
only the inspiration but also the
preservation and authority of the gospel
and Muslims say the gospel has been
corrupted they're going to face a severe
punishment from
Allah with such a terrifying warning
you'd think Muslims would investigate
this issue a bit more carefully putting
all of these pieces of evidence together
Allah says that he revealed the gospel
he says that the Quran confirms the
gospel he seems to indicate via the
Arabic phrase ma Yi that the Quan
confirms texts that were still available
in the 7th century and he says that the
gospel was to be a guidance for mankind
not something that was going to be lost
or corrupted I think we can say
definitively that Surah 3 veres 3 to
four strongly support the dwood
hypothesis over the standard Islamic
narrative next verse Surah 3: 48 we'll
start at verse 45 for context when the
angel said oh Mary truly God gives thee
Glad Tidings of a word from him whose
name is the Messiah Jesus Son of Mary
High honored in this world and the
Hereafter and one of those brought nigh
he will speak to people in the cradle
and in maturity and will be among the
righteous she said my Lord how shall I
have a child while no human being has
touched me he said thus does God create
whatsoever he will will when he decrees
a thing he only says to it be and it is
and he will teach him the book wisdom
the Torah and the gospel verse 48 is a
little confusing because it sounds like
it's talking about four different
Revelations there's the book and the
wisdom and the Torah and the gospel so
here there seems to be a distinction
between the book and other Revelations
but that's not our concern here our only
concern is that the angel tells Mary
that Allah would teach Jesus the gospel
since both the dwood hypothesis and the
standard Islamic narrative claim that
according to the Quran Allah revealed
the gospel through Jesus this verse
confirms neither hypothesis over the
other next verse Surah 3: 65 we'll start
a verse earlier for context say oh
people of the book come to a word common
between us and you
that we shall worship none but God shall
not associate ought with him and shall
not take one another as Lords apart from
God and if they turn away then say bear
witness that we are
submitters oh people of the book why do
you dispute concerning Abraham as
neither the Torah nor the gospel was
sent down until after him do you not
understand Surah 3:65 simply says that
the Torah and the gospel were revealed
after the time of Abraham so there's
nothing here that confirms either of our
hypotheses over the other next two
verses Surah 5:46 and Surah
5:47 these are back to back so we'll
read them together and in their
footsteps we sent Jesus Son of Mary
confirming the Torah that had come
before him and we gave him the gospel
wherein is a guidance and a light
confirming the Torah that had come
before him as a guidance and an
exhortation to the reverent let the
people of the Gospel judge by what God
has sent down therein whosoever judges
not by that which God has sent down it
is they who are
iniquitous lots of important details in
these two verses Allah says that he sent
Jesus confirming the Torah that had come
before him and before him here is what
MAA yedi which as we've seen means
between his hands or in his presence so
Jesus confirmed the Torah that was still
present in his time this is significant
because we have copies of the Torah from
before the time of Jesus so we know what
the Quran is confirming here Allah says
that he gave Jesus the gospel and that
the gospel contains a guidance and a
light and that the gospel confirms the
Torah meaning between his hands or in
his presence and that the Torah contains
a guidance and an
exhortation notice the similarity to
Surah 3: 3: 4 in Surah 3 3: 4 Allah said
that he revealed the Quran he said that
the Quran confirmed the Torah and the
gospel that were still available when it
was revealed and he said that the Torah
and the gospel were given as a guidance
to mankind here in Surah 5:46
Allah says that he revealed the gospel
he says that the gospel confirms the
Torah that was still available when it
was revealed and he says that the gospel
and the Torah contain a guidance I have
to point out my Muslim friends if this
is Allah trying to say that the Torah
and the gospel have been corrupted he's
doing a really really bad job of it then
we have Allah's command and warning in
Surah 5 verse 47 now if the standard
Islamic narrative is correct this would
be a perfect place to tell Christians
that the gospel has been corrupted and
that they now have to judge by the Quran
but what does Allah say he says let the
people of the Gospel judge by what God
has sent down therein Allah commands
Christians to judge not by the Quran but
by what he has sent down in the gospel
then he gives us a Stern warning
whosoever judges not by that which God
has sent down it is they who are
iniquitous if we don't judge by the
gospel we're iniquitous we're
immoral there's a fundamental principle
in ethics ought implies can if I say you
ought to do something if I say you have
a moral obligation to do something I'm
assuming that you can do it I'm assuming
that you have the ability to do it it
would make no sense for me to command
you to do something that you can't
possibly do if I tell you you have a
moral obligation to give a million
dollar to charity right now that command
only makes sense if you have a million
dollar if you don't have a million
dollars I'm commanding you to do
something you can't possibly do and it's
absurd to say you have an obligation to
do something you can't possibly do so
when Allah commands Christians to judge
by the gospel and tells us that we're
iniquitous if we don't Allah's command
assumes that we still have the gospel if
we don't have the gospel because it's
been lost or corrupted Allah's command
makes no sense because he would be
commanding us to do something that we
can't possibly do putting all these
lines of evidence together we can say
that Sora 5 verses 46 to 47 strongly
confirm the dwood hypothesis over the
standard Islamic narrative next two
verses Surah 5: 66 and Surah 5: 68 these
are closely connected so we'll read them
together and we'll start at verse 65 for
context had the people of the book
believed and been reverent we would
surely have absolved them of their evil
deeds and caused them to enter Gardens
of bliss had they observed the Torah and
the gospel and that which was sent down
unto them from their lord they would
surely have received nourishment from
above them and from beneath their feet
there is a moderate Community among them
but as for many of them evil is that
which they do oh messenger convey that
which has been sent down unto thee from
thy Lord and if thou Dost not thou Wilt
not have conveyed his message and God
will protect thee from mankind surely
God guides not disbelieving people
say oh people of the book you stand on
not till you observe the Torah and the
gospel and that which has been sent down
unto you from your lord surely that
which has been sent down unto thee from
thy Lord will increase many of them in
rebellion and disbelief so grieve not
for disbelieving people here we have a
common theme in the Quran that Jews and
Christians don't believe or aren't
reverent had they observed D the Torah
and the gospel and that which was sent
down unto them from their lord something
we can only do if we still have the
Torah and the gospel they would surely
have received nourishment from above
them and from beneath their feet another
theme in the Quran is that there is a
minority of Jews and Christians who do
believe and who do obey God the quran's
criticism of Jews and Christians is not
that we have corrupt scripture
it's never that we have corrupt
scriptures the quran's criticism of Jews
and Christians is that we don't obey our
scriptures if you think I'm wrong look
at what Allah says in verse
68 oh people of the book you stand on
knot Till You observe the Torah and the
gospel and that which has been sent down
unto you from your lord Jews and
Christians have nothing to stand on
until we obey the Torah and the gospel
remember ought implies can can we obey
the Torah and the gospel if we don't
have the Torah and the gospel no so
Allah is declaring yet again that we
still have the Torah and the gospel and
he's commanding us yet again to obey the
Torah and the gospel and it's clear yet
again that Jews and Christians are
supposed to judge by the revelations
that were given to us not by the Quran
Surah 5: 66 and 68 much like verses 46
to 47 strongly favor the dwood
hypothesis over the standard Islamic
narrative next verse Surah 5 verse 110
we'll start at verse 109 for context the
day when God will gather The Messengers
and say what response did you receive
the they will say we have no knowledge
truly it is thou who knowest best the
things unseen then God will say oh Jesus
Son of Mary remember my blessing upon
thee and upon thy mother when I
strengthened Thee with the holy spirit
that thou mightest speak to people in
the cradle and in maturity and when I
taught Thee the book wisdom the Torah
and the gospel and how thou wouldst
create out of clay the shape of a bird
by my leave and thou wouldst breathe
into it and it would become a bird by my
leave and thou wouldst heal the Blind
and the Leer by my leave and thou
wouldst bring forth the dead by my leave
and how I restrained the children of
Israel from thee when thou did bring
them clear proofs and those who
disbelieved among them said this is not
but manifest
sorcery plenty of interesting material
here but the only relevant part for this
video is Allah saying that he taught
Jesus the book wisdom the Torah and the
gospel so this is simply a law telling
Jesus to remember what happened and it's
very similar to what the angel said to
Mary in Surah
3:48 nothing new here that confirms one
hypothesis over the other next verse
Surah 7 verse 157 we'll start part of
the way through verse 156 for context
this passage is way too long to give the
complete context so I'll just summarize
the passage is about Moses going up the
mountain to receive the tablets Aaron
makes a golden calf Moses comes back
down the mountain and he's mad Allah is
mad Moses tells Allah that he shouldn't
punish them because Allah is the one who
chooses to lead people astray or guide
them and Moses finally says can't you
just prescribe good for us and then we
have Allah's response starting in verse
156 he said I cause my punishment to
Smite whomsoever I will though my Mercy
encompasses all things I shall prescribe
it for those who are reverent and give
alms and those who believe in our signs
those who follow the messenger the
unlettered prophet whom they find
inscribed in the Torah and the gospel
that is with them who enjoins upon them
what is right and forbids them what is
wrong and makes good things lawful for
them and forbids bad things and relieves
them of their burden and the shackles
that were upon them thus those who
believe in him honor him help him and
follow the light that has been sent down
with him it is they who shall prosper
this is actually very confusing because
Allah is saying this to Moses Moses asks
Allah to be merciful after Aaron made an
idol and Allah replies to Moses that he
will show Mercy to those who follow the
messenger the unlettered Prophet whom
they find inscribed in the Torah and the
gospel that is with them most Muslims
are convinced that this is referring to
Muhammad so this must have been
extremely confusing to Moses Moses would
have no clue what the gospel is and he'd
have no clue who Muhammad was and notice
what Allah says at the end of verse 157
this is supposedly referring to Muhammad
Allah says that those who believe in him
believe in Muhammad honor him help him
and follow the light that has been sent
down with him it is they who shall
prosper so Moses says can't you be
merciful and Allah replies I'm only
going to be merciful to people who
believe in Muhammad and honor him and
help him considering Muhammad wasn't
born for another 2,000 years this would
be no small task for Moses and his
followers we can only conclude if we're
being generous that Allah response to
Moses was really meant for Muhammad's
listeners when this verse was eventually
revealed since this was revealed during
the time of Muhammad the part that's
relevant for us is this those who follow
the messenger the unlettered prophet
whom they find inscribed in the Torah
and the gospel that is with them this
verse claims that mammad is prophesied
in the Torah and the gospel more
importantly Muhammad is supposedly
prophesied in the Torah and the gospel
that is with them the Torah and the
gospel that is with them the Torah and
the gospel that is with them according
to Surah 7 verse 157 when the Quran
refers to the Torah and the gospel it's
referring to the Torah and the gospel
that Jews and Christians still have with
them if Allah says he's confirming the
Torah and the gospel that are with Jews
and Christians and if we're supposed to
take the Torah and the gospel seriously
as sources of divine prophecy we
obviously can't believe that they've
been corrupted so Surah 7: 157 strongly
confirms the dwood hypothesis over the
standard Islamic narrative next verse
Surah 9 verse
111 truly God has purchased from the
Believers their souls and their wealth
in exchange for the garden being theirs
they fight in the way of God slaying and
being slain it is a promise binding upon
him in the Torah the gospel and the
Quran and who is truer to his pact than
God so rejoice in the bargain you have
made that indeed is the great Triumph
this verse says that in exchange for
Allah giving Believers Paradise they
fight for him slaying and being slain so
if you fight for Allah you know that
he's going to keep his end of the
bargain and Allah says that this promise
is binding upon him in the Torah the
gospel and the Quran I have no idea
which verse of the Gospel is supposed to
confirm this agreement but Allah says
it's there in the gospel so he confirms
that the gospel is still available it
wouldn't make much sense to say that
people should believe in a promise they
find in a corrupt book
but since there isn't much here to go on
I'll just say that this verse somewhat
favors the dwood hypothesis over the
standard Islamic narrative next verse
Surah 48: 29 Muhammad is the messenger
of God those who are with him are harsh
against the disbelievers merciful to one
another you see them bowing prostrating
seeking Bounty from God and contentment
their Mark upon their faces is from the
effect effect of prostration that is
their likeness in the Torah and their
likeness in the gospel is a sapling that
puts forth its Chute and strengthens it
such that it grows Stout and Rises
firmly upon its stock impressing the
sers that through them he may enrage the
disbelievers God has promised
forgiveness and a great reward to those
among them who believe and perform
righteous Deeds so if you're with
Muhammad then are harsh against
disbelievers and only merciful towards
fellow
Believers that's not very tolerant but
the verse goes on to say how Believers
are described in the Torah and the
gospel in the gospel Believers are
compared to a sapling that puts forth
its Chute and strengthens it such that
it grows Stout and Rises firmly upon its
stock impressing the sers and there are
passages in the gospel that say
something very similar to this this is
similar to the parable of the growing
seed and the parable of the Mustard Seed
in Mark 4 this would fit with either
hypothesis I could say that the Quran is
referring to what we still have here
Muslims could say that even though the
gospel was corrupted there are still
parts that are true what's relevant for
our discussion is that the Quran
continues to appeal to the Torah and the
gospel for confirmation of its teachings
their likeness in the gospel is
the Quran claims that this is still in
the gospel which means that the gospel
is still available and there's no
indication here that the gospel has been
corrupted so the Quran once again
appeals to the gospel for confirmation
it doesn't make much sense to appeal to
a corrupt book for confirmation I'll say
that Surah 48: 29 somewhat favors the
dwood hypothesis over the standard
Islamic narrative our final verse Surah
57: 27 then we sent our Messengers to
follow in their footsteps and we sent
Jesus Son of Mary and we gave him the
gospel and placed kindness and mercy in
the hearts of those who follow him and
monasticism they invented we did not
ordain it for them only to seek God's
contentment yet they did not observe it
with proper observance so we gave those
of them who believed their reward yet
many of them are
iniquitous here the Quran once again
claims that the gospel was given to
Jesus we have the added bonus that Allah
says that he placed kindness and mercy
in the hearts of those who follow Jesus
so Christians are kind and merciful
according to the Quran Allah says that
Christians invented monasticism he's
saying he didn't reveal that instead he
told Christians to seek God's
contentment but he says Christians
haven't observe that with proper
observance notice the Quran always
criticizes Christians for not obeying
what he revealed in the gospel and for
inventing certain practices that he
didn't command Allah never ever ever
condemns our scriptures or gives even
the slightest hint that our scriptures
can't be trusted and we know this
because we've now gone through every
single Quran verse that mentions the
gospel
since Surah 57: 27 fits with either of
our hypothesis we'll say that it doesn't
confirm one over the other although we
could argue that if the standard Islamic
narrative were correct Allah should be
saying in all or at least some of these
verses that the gospel has been
corrupted returning to our two
hypotheses we have the dwood
hypothesis according to the Quran Allah
gave different Revel ations to different
groups of people through different
prophets and those different groups of
people are responsible for obeying the
scriptures that were revealed to them
Christians received the gospel through
Jesus the gospel is still reliable and
authoritative and Christians are
commanded to judge by the gospel not by
the Quran then we have the standard
Islamic narrative according to the Quran
Allah gave different Revelations to
different groups of people but they were
all corrupted except the Quran
Christians received the gospel through
Jesus but they corrupted it the gospel
is not reliable or authoritative and
Christians must now judge by the Quran
not by the gospel after reading every
single verse in the Quran that mentions
the gospel we've seen that four verses
348 365 51 10 and
5727 confirm neither hypothesis over the
other two verses 9111 and 4829 somewhat
confirm the dwood hypothesis over the
standard Islamic narrative and six
verses 33 546 547 566 568 and
7157 strongly confirm the dwood
hypothesis over the standard Islamic
narrative there isn't a single verse
anywhere in the Quran that confirms the
standard Islamic narrative over the
dwood
hypothesis Allah repeatedly affirms the
inspiration of the Gospel he repeatedly
affirms the preservation of the gospel
and he repeatedly affirms the authority
of the Gospel Christians are commanded
to obey the gospel in fact we're told
that we have no ground to stand on until
we obey the gospel Christians are
criticized and condemned for not obeying
the gospel Allah never says one word not
one word in the entire Quran that's even
slightly critical of the text we have
before us and what do all of our Muslim
friends say don't believe the gospel
don't judge by the gospel the gospel has
been corrupted you can't trust the
gospel everyone has to judge judge by
the Quran
now they say the exact opposite of what
Allah says in the Quran and then they
tell us to believe in the Quran when
they clearly don't believe in it my
Muslim friends how can you possibly tell
us to respect the Quran when you don't
respect the Quran at all how can you
possibly tell us to obey Allah when you
also tell us not to obey Allah if tells
us over and over again to obey the
gospel and he tells us over and over
again yes I'm talking about the gospel
that Christians still have and then you
say no don't obey the gospel because you
definitely don't have the gospel you're
telling us that Allah is either a liar
or a complete
you're telling us that Allah is
the worst Communicator in
history why would we take the Quran
seriously when when according to you it
was revealed by a liar or a complete
your God affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of our book
you tell us not to believe what your God
says but to believe your book
anyway if we can't trust your book when
it talks about our book why would we
trust your book at
all a more important question for you
would
this when your God tells you one thing
and your lying shakes and imams tell you
the exact
opposite why do you side with your lying
shakes and imams and not with your
God why do you call yourselves Muslims
people who submit to God when you really
submit to your lying shakes and imams
who insult and degrade your
God and since you've decided to submit
to a bunch of liars and not to God why
do you want us to join you in submitting
to the biggest bunch of liars the world
has ever seen
[Music]